now i hope you have been saving words
and
learning these words or at least
reviewing them don't worry if you
remember them you're going to forget
them
but now you should
try to save phrases because very often
the individual words don't give you a
good sense of what the words mean
together in a phrase if you save the
phrase you'll hear the text to speech
you'll get a translation which may or
may not always be accurate but i find
mostly it is
and then you want to review these
phrases because phrases have the
advantage
that that they help you prepare to speak
because when you go to speak you want to
use words that kind of belong together
that are normally used together so you
should get used to these direct your
attention to these phrases by saving
them you will notice that other users
have saved phrases and you'll see these
sort of outlined for you suggested as
example phrases that you could save
where possible save phrases and review
them it'll be a big boost to your
language learning good luck